if i unhooked my insulin pump right now
i would be in a coma within eight to 12
hours and
i would be dead without medical
intervention in about 48 hours i need
insulin 24 7 365 for the rest of my life
i'm laura marshton a 39 year old dc
resident and a patient with type 1
diabetes
please on behalf of seven million
americans who need insulin to survive
investigate insulin price fixing
my first bile of fumalog i remember
going with my mom to the pharmacy to get
it in the very first file she paid 25
at the time my reaction was
oh my gosh a vial only lasts me about a
week or a week and a half so i'm quickly
doing the math in my head you know 25 is
a lot of money and
you multiply that by essentially how
many weeks i want to live and
that seemed astronomical and i said to
my mother at the time what happens if
they do raise the price or how do i
afford this she said the government
would never let that happen
but then fast forward
to today and the government has let that
happen rising anger over the
skyrocketing cost of insulin in march of
2004 a vial of insulin ran about 56
dollars now
that exact same insulin cost
295 dollars so this is showing the price
increases for insulin so everything in
this yellow orange color is a price
increase that's already happened i've
calculated how much i will have to pay
to live to the age of 70
and it's almost 6 million dollars just
for the insulin alone
over 20 years they raised the prices
by an average of 15 a year
year after year after year after year so
a vial that was 20
in 1996 is now 320
so
what's happened is they've taken these
insulins that that aren't new that have
been on the market for decades and just
increased the price because we have to
pay or die and they know that
so i save all my old files because i
call them my insulin drags there's a
little bit in each vial that with a tiny
syringe i could get out maybe 20 30
units and most of these are expired like
just glancing at the dates it's like
2018
and 2018
um
so that would be long expired because
insulin is only good for a year
but this is my uh backup emergency stash
right here
you know we're talking i'm in a bad bad
situation and
that's better than nothing
making insulin more affordable is a top
priority for democrats so right now
there are bipartisan talks underway led
by senator shaheen and collins to cap
insulin at 35 a month and make changes
to drive the cost down in a
comprehensive way the bill that's been
proposed by senator schumer and senator
warnock says if you are fortunate enough
to be able to afford and keep
health insurance
then the copay that you pay on top of
your premiums
for each insulin you take
can't be over 35
but
the big caveat there is if you're
uninsured
insulin remains three hundred dollars a
vial insulin remains
thousand dollars a month the bill
doesn't address the price of insulin
likely because pharma doesn't want to
lower the price of insulin
when pharmaceutical companies have
a blank check for seven million
americans to say how much will you pay
not to die how much will you pay for
this insulin
they have a lot of money on almost
endless supply
to pump back in the form of campaign
donations political donations political
action committees they use those to
influence policy
please stop taking money from insulin
makers that money is from my no longer
existent retirement account
stop using it to fund your campaigns
stop falling for the formal lobbying
routine you were voted into office to
represent patients not corporations
i just wish we could have an honest
conversation that wasn't
influenced by pharma money i wish we
could as a country say is this right or
is this wrong okay if we agree this is
wrong then we're going to do something
about it and when it comes to being
extorted and being priced gouged for the
insulin you need to live
that's something we can change and
that's something that we
need to change and that's something that
my life depends on us changing
[Music]